everyone and welcome to the second of
david may use Stimson's lectures on the
imprint of Congress I just want to take
one minute to welcome you all here and
and David the Stimson election series is
the the longest established and most
distinguished lecture series at the
Macmillan Center it's produced books
such as Samuel Huntington's political
order in changing societies shellings
arms and influence and very interesting
book coming shortly coming out from
Michael Walzer which was Simpson
lectures last year called what happened
to national liberation so I think and
Mayhew's Stimson lecture book which will
be published next year by yell press
will certainly belong in this company I
would just say one thing about David he
needs no introduction here so I'm not
going to give him an extensive one
particularly since nobody came here to
listen to me today but I would just say
that that David Mayhew's all the time
I've been here is the platonic form of a
colleague and if you said how do you
measure that how do you measure
collegial ness the many ways one can do
that but the way I think of it is if
when I give my work to people to read
and you ask yourself who gives you kind
of comments that actually make you
change what you win he's right at the
top of the list and he's and I think
that's the most useful thing a colleague
can do for you and it's been great to
have all your support all these years so
welcome and this is the second of these
three lectures on the imprint of
Congress focusing on the history
I think it took some of my pages theory
and they do the first and second page
baby I guess how and there's another one
there's own yeah that's it that'll do it
that's it okay yep alright thanks is it
Mike working okay and the screen is
working ok everything worked very nicely
yesterday and that's you know a
wonderful set up here where I left us to
did it yesterday the imprint of Congress
I said I'm on a hunt for Congress's
distinctive impact across American
history 225 years or the Republican each
of a sequence of 13 transnational
impulses that the USA is participated in
in all that time and I yes there it is
and here it because let me give you the
timeline again this is what I put on the
boy last time and i'll put it up again
just as a preface to what I'm doing
today these are the 13 items that i will
have talked about at the end of this are
we okay no this might get pushed away I
see so okay we're okay now is that
better we're doing better is it enough
okay good thanks for coming up that's
great yep all right ah yes now yes so
there are 13 and I covered the first of
them yesterday since I my time ran out
and what I was ball behaving about
yesterday and I'm saving the number 12
and 13 the beginning of next Tuesday so
I want to cover 10 of these impulses
today Senate that's a lot that means not
more than about four and a half minutes
per item so I need to trundle right
along it's a lot of stuff here a lot of
material I mean next tuesday i'm going
to do be more interpretive and talking
about these things but today it's a
presentation of stuff basically what
i'll try to do is to tease out some
interesting stories about these matters
as i go through as they go through and
each case i want to give you the
transnational setting understand that
these are transnationally appearing
impulses that's part of the technique
and i'll talk about what the American
executive branch has been up to and then
I'll talk about what Congress has been
up to that'll be the frame for each
discussion all not necessarily exactly
in that order and again next tuesday i
want to say yes the interpretations i
will want to link agent next tuesday
they cover only so much that is i'll
pick out some themes that will bore into
a number of these these items going
over the 13 but they won't cover
everything there are particular era teas
here there's a kind of dog's breakfast
quality to the to these 13 things I'll
put together in some respects I think
but that's okay that's not my fault
there are some surprises and in some
cases i'll just let a particular
allottees particular a latina bout today
just stand there put them on the table
and leave them that's the way I'm going
to do it yes if but it's yes it's as I
say there is some surprises and I think
a lot of the stories are interesting
last time I did the first of these
launch of a new nation it was Hamilton
day remember I was the of Broadway that
all we talked about Hamilton somebody
else on me today you got to go see that
we did that I need to do it again
there's the contribution then of the
executive branch which is major for the
creation of the American sistance in the
American public they always put put out
by Hamilton structuring the finance
financial arrangements of the country
and they as much as anything they made
for the evidently for the economic
prosperity up here up here in North
America during the 19th century there it
was Congress I thought contributed a
legitimizing role and I'll just stop it
and leave it there we want to go on now
we want to go on to the next one which
is this the Second Continental expansion
continental expansion this is the only
the center is the first half of the 19th
century and here is here is an impulse
are they the participation of which i
think is really quite appalling I told
you last time that the term performance
doesn't necessarily carry the positive
valence this is one instance where it
doesn't but still I'm using the term
performance at the time people who
defined about things that way probably
and probably at least for that reason
the term is merited but I'm not saying I
approved to went back on of what went on
during these at decades before the civil
war in this respect during this to
transnational set a continental
expansion that means across North
America by the by the by the American
the Americans the English the British
settlers as they went west what was
happening across a set a transnational
set of countries at this time and
actually the time sprawls a little back
and also into the 1870s and 80s as you
look around the world is that european
peoples were moving in with what they
saw its vacant spaces that is the
American West Australia New Zealand of
Siberia at one point the cone countries
of Latin America these are places
inhabited by indigenous
people yet they were they were places to
be taking over after all and inhabited
and used and their use of [ __ ] taken
advantage of by european people's move
again of whom door a lot I mean the
settler pressure was just amazing in the
1830s and 40s apparently coming from
Great Britain into these places just
amazing and the the u.s. is just one of
a pack and most respects here no better
no worse pretty bad pretty brutal it's
the the ethnic cleansing that we see in
the u.s. under and especially in
jacksonian times and the presidents in
the 1830s it's just eerily similar to
what was going on in Tasmania and new
south wales that as those now states of
Australia at that at that time yes but
in yes so the Americans so let me call
NEMA they took over a lot of land and
then they did something with it the role
of the executive during this and we're
just talking just about the US air now
which makes you feel good presidency
what's this the the executive acquired
the land seized the land got the land
that is that there it was that's what
executive dude sometimes in the
initiative was there from Jefferson
through pulk that's going out and
getting land from other people from the
Spanish from the French from the British
from the Indians taking it over for use
by the Americans it was done by these
are familiar stories by purchased by
annexation by warfare by rampages by
schemes down on the southern borders
that would look to us tonight put an
desk I mean what Putin's doing in the
east of Ukraine is rather similar to
what some of these presents was doing
down and what will call the Florida's at
the time the Florida's at the time
extended all the way from they'll watch
Florida West to almost New Orleans they
were called the Florida's and the
Americans are going down there and doing
these things yes it's so it's that's
what it is seizure of land and
displacement of Indians displacement or
killing of Indians to take that land the
Cherokee Nation went out for example a
major actor in this after aussie well
note was andrew jackson both as a
general in the 20th or before that and
then as a president in the 1830s daniel
walker how the greatest Orion has in one
of his recent books a very thick book
the question what is jacksonian
democracy and his answer is well in the
first place it's about the extension of
white supremacy across the North
American continent and now we're saying
they were we say okay you know now
Jefferson's and Jackson's pictures are
going to the
all if you read know about these
Democratic that governments are giving
up on jefferson jackson they did is I
don't know what they're going to rename
them but Jay and we're not deny J&J
anymore all right now enough of that
that's pretty familiar the role of
Congress and all this this it's a
different component of it it's one of
the most interesting literature's that
came across it's a big literature a very
fine literature and it's not a new and
no literature in this case it's just
newly discovered by me this literature
once I got the land what do they do with
it well it was Jerry was Congress's job
took on they presided just distributing
the land getting rid of the Lamb the
land comes into public possession by the
USA then what happens to it just immense
quantities of land west of the
Alleghenies all the way finally to the
west coast and take it from Mexico a lot
of it well Congress made the rules it
didn't execute the rules but Congress
it's it's a switch in making the rules
for getting rid of this land its public
land you understand at the start and is
it what's going to happen to it is it
going to become private now Congress
started at all this in the mid 1780s
actually before 1787 a Scott mentioned
system Scott in this book seeing eye
steak with what an astonishing move this
is one of the most one of the most
rationalistic master plans ever
generated by a legislature came in the
mid mid seventeen 1780s that was to
divide up the whole country these little
rectangles which would define what the
plots would be of land across the
country that's extremely rational astok
that's that kind of thing that
legislators are duralee do but after
that over seven decades of trademark I
think trademark congressional politics
is what happened getting rid of the land
I mean this is a politician's dream it's
amazing that any politician ever lost an
electron in the US during these decades
we look they had all this land to give
away Wenders love that if you're a
politician it's it's easier to taking
money out of the treasury when you don't
have taxation it's a it was a bit
immense fund of felicity for politicians
incumbent politicians during these
decades here's what it was like
disposing of the land the here are the
themes during these again about seven
decades of themes keep lowering the land
prices that pleases people out there the
selling it eventually they went down to
zero in the 1860s and giving it away
keep allowing smaller land plots because
that's what people wanted farmers allow
easy credit people wanted to borrow out
there so I think you get the land then
supplied debt relief once the farmer
debt piles up just do that then
legitimize the squatters there are
always people coming onto the land and
taking it over they got to figure out
what to do with them one answer was to
let them have the land after they lived
there and that generally speaking that's
what happened accommodate the warrant
veterans as veterans benefits before the
Civil War a modern mostly to giving
people land if they'd served in wars and
then don't worry about the government
making any money and in fact is all this
could you go to made a fortune out of
this by selling this land but at the end
of the day they about broke even the
government and then finally keep
changing the rules over and over again
decade after decade it's fascinating its
populace it's kind of a ragged messy
volatile populism that would describes
this this disposing of the land over a
long period of time and this was
sometimes should this to the despair of
the executives the connection who didn't
like some of this I mean that includes
Hamilton includes Dinah Andrew Jackson
it includes a Gallatin the Jeffersonian
a financial later yeah executive don't
like to operate like this sometimes and
this is an incident alright that's that
one on to the next one midnight century
mid-nineteenth century consolidation and
here's here's what I'm here's what I'm
thinking of here the I'm putting it at
as basket I kind of like this
interpretation some some historians to
come down with about the mid 19th 19th
century particularly the 1860s they
aren't buying into them here bay CA
Bailey nice book 2003 in questioning the
emergent federate state we're talking
about the Civil War here and they
abandoned the abolishing of slavery of
the USA the union was itself following
or contributing to a much wider
realignment in which logic unified
nations and one centralized and
economically sophisticated supremacist
replace the still loose and varied
policies of the early 19th century and
this is similar similar analysis here by
the great comparative historian I think
EJ hobsbawm written back and I think
published anyway last time in 1996 for
one reason or another three types of a
gray and Ed prize are under pressure
that serfdom various yes
as he's got surface States additional
non-capitalist president economies and
slavery so what we had across much of
the world in the 80s entering in the
1860s and I don't know why this happened
nobody's got a good account I mean Bob
swamp opines what's going on is that
we're saying here the effects among
other things of the immense changes in
communications and transportation to
come down in these various places doing
the preceding generation or maybe that's
true it's really a revolution something
like the internet revolution to bring in
the Telegraph at that time but I don't
know anyway there's a movement many
places to centralize governments to
bring in stronger nationalisms to to a
good for a wider citizenship rights to
people and generally we think i read
it's a modernizing liberalism that said
it in many of these countries not France
and England some months and also I'd
already done many of these things but
Germany Italy Mexico other places the
USA in the consolidation of the union of
the defeat of the Confederacy at all
during the during during the Civil War
now the roles of the of the institutions
I mean the this was the executive after
all is the center of what happened in
the US Lincoln in the 1860s it's the
civil wars is an executive enterprise
it's a it's brutal its military its
violent it's that's what it is is it
edge of steel and violence of the whole
business it's a it's I mean Lincoln is
sometimes compared to Bismarck and
Kabore who are the unifiers of Germany
under the brush once and of Italy also
at that same same juncture rhythm in
19th century it'sit's then after the war
came the occupation of the south by the
America the Union Army which is a key
key ingredient a fascinating new book
about that by the way by Gregory downs
called after a comma after Appomattox
anybody seen that book but he's just a
wonderful book about the reconstruction
and during the years following the Civil
War in our point in the union army was
and down there without no Union Army no
doubt reconstruction's when I come down
to its so yes now I'm not going to talk
much about Congress here because I want
to leave it's very important but I want
to leave the discussion until tuesday
i'm going to come i'm going to enfold
what i want to say about congress at
this juncture in a mirror
in history into a larger discussion so
I'm going to leave it generally speaking
what I would say here is that what you
find among Congress is a propensity of
all the time most of the time anyway a
propensity to way and to accommodate
intensities among voters however those
voters may be various times and during
these decades 50 1850s 1860s 1870s the
voting universe changes greatly so for
various reasons through various moves
well save that little too statement how
we doing we're doing all right next on a
building an industrial economy after I
hear and I want to Santa run after the
Civil War or starting in the mid 1860s
USA's conventional interpretation if I
didn't Bearden and Charles beard and
others what we do find in the last
decades of the 19th century is just just
immense surge and many leading economies
toward the development of large-scale
industrial industrial capitalism if this
emanates among other things in rival
continuing rivalry with Britain and
later rivalry with Germany is as the
history heads into nineteen odom just
after that these are your great economic
powers by 1900 or so in the in the USA
is somebody's interpretation of the
1860s this destructive though it was I
think this is a conventional
interpretation the Civil War broke the
slave aqua seized power to obstruct an
American developmental agenda
economically thinking's i mean the the
guards are off there could go there
could be adjusted at the economy could
flex its muscles with people you there
in good now what happened after all of
course in the development of the
capitalist big scale economy of the
nineteenth century was very dominantly a
private sector thing i mean the
government wasn't building railroads I
never would happen it was that it was
the the lord the robber barons and all
that the coming of the railroads the
coming of the steel industry the coming
of areas mining companies and so on all
that we know that it's a very private
kind of thing but that doesn't mean
there's no place there's no place for
the government in this enterprise this
if it is an enterprise it's the
development rather than enterprise is
something that came about rather than
enterprise in a sense that is it is it
isn't if everybody
people put up their heads in 1865 and
says let's develop an industrial economy
they didn't do that but rather it did
happen it was an end state that came
about in the relevant country one can
compare with each other as I set forth
as a comparison goal or standard last
time well now this in the US though and
the government had it has a big role it
just what I'm going to say he is
reasonably conventional although I look
carefully at it to find out what the
wrinkles are and what the problems are I
think in the interpretations during
these decades it's about eighteen sixty
when I was eighteen sixty five up to
Willow on something like that or maybe 3
1900 difficult to say it's on my
timeline there was a kind of a division
of labor that is the the the executive
branch the presidency the Treasury
Department the generally speaking they
they protected the currency that if they
thought they thought I was very
important to maintain a stable currency
the rest of the world the rest of the
developed world out during this time was
on the gold standard and therefore the
Americans should be on the gold standard
to which should cause problems of
deflation it which it did by the end of
the century but the one of the guiding
augments wasn't it ought to get
investment from Europe which was really
needed the u.s. in the late 19th century
to build the railroads and otherwise you
have to have the kind of stable economy
with a stable and currency which will
attract European money which may well
have been true there it was so I don't
think that's a the executive protect the
gold standard also they helped
occasionally they'd help to manage
currency crisis so they weren't very
good at it they perk up and try to do it
occasionally and also they put down
strikes in the the presidency during
those decades what do they wondering
this is not looked at too much in the
history of emphasize too much we put
down nationwide strikes this is rocky
time in the industrial order this is 70s
through World War one strikes went down
by President Hayes the Republican in
1877 by grover cleveland democrat in
1894 they're all doing it there it was
that it was the division of labor the
courts during these decades it's much
written about that i'm ignoring the
courts in this analysis by going to
bring them up here briefly i regret
ignoring them but i don't know much
about them the role of the courts to
guard property rights and to protect
interstate markets basically that is
markets across the American States
against the intrusions by frisky state
legislators the Supreme Court was doing
that now but Congress Congress during
these years
Congress doing is what we see is a kind
of distributed devout call it
distributed developmental ISM that is
passing out passing out goodies benefits
to the end of trying to in Goose along
the economy the Pacific Railway act of
the mid-1860s the land-grant College Act
does get the college kids in more
college kids into learning engineering
and that sort of thing homestead act as
a free land out in the West the
protective tariffs Congress is heavy
into putting up and it was a
congressional well the president's
haven't liked the tariff that much most
of them they've almost always liked it
less than Congress does the Congress is
a it's the distributive benefits kind of
thing and Congress does traffic in that
and that sort of politics very nicely
and eagerly sometimes as will give you
this you that you that you that get it
together or nom the bus bill that makes
people very unhappy in on capitol hill
and across the country people who
received those things to act in that
fashion now it's one of the pictures of
one of the one of the one of the
justifications of or one of the one that
one of the explanations of the high
tariff propensity of Congress during
those signs it was more than that it was
a Republican party platform the high
tariff was a way of competing with the
British economy it's not just a
distributive Christmas tree kind of
thing though Christmas tree is a part of
it and Congress had a bent to add silver
and inflation more so than the president
see the silver or the president the
congressman they like silver that is
some of the small states out in the West
they had silver mines the states would
send people that they see who know there
and talk about silver all the time that
happened right into the 1930s it was
that presidents as we kind of like that
now there are this is conventional I
think what I'm saying here about these
times but I came away thinking that the
scholarship of this period is if
anybody's interested in getting at a
scholarship about this sort of thing
it's very stale that is what we don't
have a very good picture of what the
government was up to in its scheming and
it's putting together policies in the
Treasury and on the hill and it's an
interesting question if you think back
in those science for example before the
federal reserve board came along in 1913
through creation the the stuff that the
federal now does was divided between
Capitol Hill and the Treasury
Department's interesting they both took
a roll it wasn't with resided in one
place that is worrying about the
currencies
and so forth was it was a court
sometimes the cooperative and sometimes
sometimes competitive between those
institutions an interesting time but it
needs more work on next I want to talk
about I called this one the taping the
corporations and the rich and the
timeline on this is the late 19th
century what is the date and I guess I
put at the 1890 through right up through
the nineteen thirty something like that
taming the corporations and the rich the
story on this one is that made dustrial
capitalism came along after all it's a
great big thing it was wonderful in some
senses and people thought it was thurs
per capita income in the West tripled
over a course of truck a few couple of
generations and that is immense and
Felicity's came down like being able can
I came along like they'd be able to
write on a train order something through
a mail-order catalog they couldn't do
those things in the 1840s he's a very
nice on the other hand there is a this
is a lot of disruption and discontent
what attended the coming of we know that
this is we learned this over eleven of
industrial capitalism during these times
it strikes there are immense of
immigration people coming in and getting
getting working very hard in the
workplace or sweatshops it's a lot of
market volatility which afflicted
farmers and also afflicted the economy
generally generally during during these
decades so it's so it's kind of dicey so
there's a reaction against this and it's
not just in the US again it's a
transnational thing these are the
decades in which across the comparable
countries the set of countries we get
the development of socialism the
socialist parties yeah Marx is writing
earlier but the great socialist parties
come about in the late 19th century left
liberalism comes into style in Great
Britain I mean the Liberal Party changes
its spots roughly about 1900 in the US
we get large doses of populism and
progressivism in the late nineteenth
early early 20th century these are peer
peer enterprises a city that is to say
comparable enterprises in these places
the US what happened in particular is
what I came about is good writing about
this by several people really cently as
a powerful what they call it
anti-monopoly woman it was a buzz phrase
from a century ago anti-monopoly
movement it's a you know a big noun on
the left
depressed for regulation of business and
for progressive taxation through several
decades both farmers and laborers were
involved in it it's but it's a
particular American twist to it all I
mean socialism is pretty weak in the US
after all as an enterprise but the
thrust toward business regulation and
progressive taxation with major it was
the is probably the American entry into
the comparison of this of this this
impulse which went across these various
countries now the story here I think is
this that the conventional accounts of
all this they have too much presidential
ism you know Teddy Roosevelt did this
Woodrow Wilson to that FDR did that love
to have an ass the end of the story but
that's really very very it's it's it's
it's it's it's off its off its off
there's a lot more going on on Capitol
Hill and vow and in fact I think it's
fair to say that Congress took the lead
generally speaking over many decades and
regulatory and regulatory activity and
in framing the time that they're of the
progressive revenue system over many
it's quite interesting to see what they
could do on the hill railroad regulation
isn't let's see my first quote there
this is a Grover Cleveland took no part
in any stage of the formative process of
the intent is estate commerce acting in
his message you never mentioned that
which which is interesting right sure
other railroad regulation going into the
20th century labor laws labor laws
tended to come from Congress that is
labor labor management regulation laws
leave beyond the the firm what it would
be the Davis davis-bacon Act and I think
31 for example with construction workers
the well I'm reaching right into the
1930s here the the the norris-laguardia
ACT 1932 it's an important labor law
bubbles right out of the hill it's not a
presidential thing and also the Wagner
Act the biggest of them all the Wagner
Act the National Labor Relations Act in
1935 this is very much senator Wagner's
baby in senator Wagner in New York is
just an absolutely major figure in the
American policy history operate on
Capitol Hill to 20 years or so with
great great impact he discovered how to
have a talented staff and he used it as
a senator in those days sealy what have
I got here the the third quote down the
National Labor Relations Act
35 Wagner was the axe legislative and
got you know he had to Roosevelt was a
hard sell on this one and usually we say
the way the Roosevelt did it but it's
really not correct when he signed on to
it what's the Senate had passed it but
they've been the White House have been
going to get a block and they didn't
really like this plan this kind of a
plan to doing things but then went on to
the books is this mic working ok we're
doing all right all right yes and
progressive excuse me yesterday please I
will did I have it up here yesterday is
that better okay good I'm glad you told
me that's fine that's very good yep i'm
glad i asked also that's fine okay a
progressive taxation is a very
interesting story the I mean it was
Congress that put forth that income tax
first in 1894 which was enacted over
Gregory Cleveland wouldn't sign it was
enacted anyway then the court struck it
down it was Congress also that generated
the 16th amendment in 1909 that is the
income tax amendment and who devised the
mix of the tax in 1913 first time there
was it next but then the interesting so
I think the most interesting story is
from is from nineteen nineteen sixteen
when the one the government need money
to get ready for world war one they
needed immense amounts of money to
conduct will roll one and and they and
they and so what do they do well the
Democrats are running Capitol Hill
they're also running the presidency with
Wilson it's not as if it was great
conflict between the democratic White
House and the Democrats on the hill
nonetheless the pressure for the
successful pressure for a pretty Steph
progressive tax regime came from the
hill you see what's this is from the
economic mystery writer Elliott Brownlee
at the bottom what is the the
progressive minded Democratic insurgents
it could insisted have preparedness for
the war later the war effort were to
move forward they could do so only on
the insurgents financial terms and the
White House signed on to that and let
that meant bringing in a mix of Taxation
involving an estate tax which came out
of the books for the first time in 1916
corporate taxation and heavy income
personal income taxation that's a mix
that dates to 1916
and it's stuck it's been with us ever
since that mix now the rates have gone
up and down and some other features of
the will one taxes were dumped in the
1920s but nonetheless that basic mix of
taxation which is quite interesting
dates to congressionally to
congressional initiative in 1916 it's
quite interesting I mean this of this
hole I call it think about this as a
taxon or regulatory regime during these
many decades it was a kind of position
taking politics I mean a simple
appealing messages of blame and remedy
that could be put out there by
politicians and acted on by Congress and
there it was and I mean the taxation the
progressive taxation modes were quite
striking look at the look at the last
quota guy here by the kitty about what
does he say very high taxes and the very
rich was he's using the whole thing as a
phrase for the as a noun phrase the stat
the sentence in fenton in the United
States and he's looking at these
developments of the first couple of
decades of the 20th century we don't say
anything like a pressure for high
taxation today that was there and this
these these progressive day marshes of
the first half of the first couple of
decades the money a century onward to
the next one Michael Cato Mike okay the
rise of world power now a lot can be
said and I'm not going to say it it's a
it's a near malton vows after the Civil
War right up and so almost current
science maybe current times it's hard to
say rival of rivalry among nation states
USA the UK Germany Russia the rest of
them all the way along is it's very
familiar story and I need again it's a
lot I'm going to not not going to say
very much it could give a full lecture
on this one the but I want to say this
distinguishing the branches that is the
mean action prone this has very
ordinarily come from the president's
when this did and
and when the Congress is different for
the executive branch on policy the
president generally speaking has been
the proactive ones not surprising is
what you'd expect from a presidency as
opposed to a legislature but there it is
Jefferson said his ships to the to the
shores of North Africa at 1803 Obama
sends his drones to the Middle East in
2015 that's very much an executive kind
of thing to do after all it's not
surprising I got the impression that
over history they the executive branch
taken alone the presidency within it
take him right there they would have
operated given their propensity they
would have operated this country
something like the British Empire the
same kind of impulses and activities
whereas Congress you look at the way
they operate the way they think they
kind of prefer a sort of a large
Switzerland you know just leave them
alone I mean the Congress is they talk a
lot and sometimes they talked as if they
really want to fight but generally
speaking I think the story on the
Congressional site is insularity that is
they really don't like to be disturbed
by the rest of the world the average
voter is not much interested in what's
going on in the rest of the world and
the Congress kate is an awful lot to
your average voter out there so Congress
is often foot dragged or resisted White
House aims for expansions or for
invasions or for intrusion so for
annexations or but also for commitments
abroad all these reaches out to the rest
of the world sometimes to grab things in
the rest of the world congress has
unbalanced and especially when there's
some difference in opinion between the
institution's been been a foot dragger I
mean for there is a this was true in the
yeah it's hmm say I mean they turned
down the Versailles Treaty in 1990 they
turned out they wouldn't let the you
Congress wouldn't join the World Court
in the 1930s they was isolationism in
the 30s as the helicopter exit from
Vietnam in 1975 visit there there it is
a lot of there's a lot of that they
night now they won't approve of Iran's a
Obama's Iranian deal you notice and I
think that if to go back a year or so
whenever it was Obama had sent up to
Congress his plan which he announced
he's going to do after all the Doosan
bombing in Syria they would have
rejected that too I think it's backed
away from it from funding it up for the
reason
they set it up he would have lost on
Capitol Hill the way the David Cameron
they had a Britain in Boston the British
crown which was previously that by
sending something up I think yeah
there's a lot to me that's all I want I
thought 11 interesting story there's an
interesting story that comes out of this
I think a distinctive imprint of
Congress when you put the US against
some other countries like in this case
France and Britain the USA became an
imperial power with imperial power at a
big one without becoming much of a
colonial power that is a shortage of
colonies out there shortage decision to
say the US have very influenced in an
awful lot of countries in the world
because they do but formally controlled
colonies in the way in India was the
Britain or french west africa was to
france is a great shortage of that given
american power and a reason for that is
that Congress i just hadn't liked as
resisted having colonies it's a you see
that over and over again from the 1860's
through the 1920s which is probably the
decisive time for colonial acquisitions
in the world the kept saying no they
they they a lot of reasons i mean one of
them simply racism I mean most places
they could have been taken over by the
USA did not have white populations and
on Capitol Hill they went they didn't
fancy the idea of having more non-whites
in the country though that's where it
was why it's the only kind of country in
the view of most most members of
Congress at most times is interesting
story about the Philippines the u.s. did
take the Philippines in 1890 and
actually this is a kind of an acceptance
of my story it's one of the rare times
in American history when Congress has
been out front in an aggressive way in
helping to spur the spanish-american war
in 1898 so it was kind of exceptional in
what I'm talking about but they took the
Philippines but then in the 1930s they
voted to really voted philippine
independence that's before the french
and british were shutting off their
colonies since interesting why they did
it the Capitol Hill took the initiative
a bunch of reason is fascinating there
was simply anti-imperialism which is a
pretty strong strain on Capitol Hill it
was racism after all the Filipinos
aren't our whites would they were
anti-immigration in the 1930s during
their in native s during the Depression
they were there was wage competition
from Filipinos coming in on the west
coast is rioting in California about
Philippine is coming out on the west
cause the sugar interested wanna tech
wanted to put up tariffs against
Philippine sugar and they could do it as
long as the u.s. own developed a lot of
reasons there they put them all together
and they voted philippine independence
even though one point who were vetoed it
they got it through a Roosevelt went
along with it that's enough for that one
onward responded you the Great
Depression now the Great Depression
afflicted all over the place Japan
Germany everywhere it was a shared
plight in nineteen thirty-one thirty-two
thirty-three people think finger to it
solutions what to do this will wave and
no interesting scholarship here in this
case and the executive I think the short
story is this one as they the exact
franklin roosevelt made the big moves i
mean this is this is what's this it's as
canonical and involve now it's not
exactly could a nautical it's just i
think it becoming canonical they going
off the gold standard what's the thing
to do and he did it finally in nineteen
thirty-three thirty-four that seems to
have made that that's what the Economist
seem to be selling today that made the
big difference it wasn't fiscal policies
monetary policy they made the difference
in generating the occur the recovery and
a Roswell did it it was his stuff it was
it was then they bet the hundred days of
legislating which Roosevelt guided
1933-34 help to stabilize the economy
through regulating this that or another
thing crop prices mortgages securities
and so on so laurels still have got to
go FDR there at the executive Congress's
case during the Depression I think
generally speaking the order long with F
they are there was not much friction not
that much friction between the White
House and the and the and Congress on
all this if it's the first thing that is
how they did distinguish though they
distinguished in some respects that is
Congress has more Pro inflation there's
they're still silver there's sin solid
silver people came from Nevada in places
like that they wanted to bail out the
solar industry that means inflation go
for inflation they had farmer interests
that were going for inflation the
whiteout didn't like that it was also
the most interesting story has to do
with veterans benefits that is veterans
bonus was the world well one's better
veterans bonus which had to be paid out
the world worldwide wouldn't back there
very far and I'd speak I mean there's
been writing about this by economist
going
back to nineteen fifty-six butts a
particularly good recent writing about
this about the importance of Congress's
voting veterans bonus bonuses during the
1930s that's what happened was they
voted big payouts of bonuses in 1931 who
were vetoed they passed over his veto
that did it again 1936 passed over Rosa
bells veto and the bonus money went out
and it was big money big money going
into the economy I would guess from our
reading the various people that of the
fiscal backhoe economic counter cyclical
stuff that's done by the government
during the 1930s veterans boniface rank
very high they may indeed rank in first
place you know other stuff didn't go
very far according to christina romer
the the bonus in 1936 was very big and
so his a one account of the economic
recovery recovery in 1936 is more than
took one two and a half times greater
than the preceding two years and the
veterans bonus paid out in june seemed
to have been the basis of that it's a
big thing America in general during the
Depression I mean American handling of
the depression it's it's better than
generic across the whole bunch of [ __ ]
he's probably a no cigar the British
probably did things just as well and
some things that the government did
during the 30s probably didn't help much
soon to get outside of the depression
and they have heard for example big tax
hikes that Hoover signed in 1932 in the
Roosevelt signed at 35 and 36 the
National Recovery Act in 33 well it's
not a great thing according to most
economists yes belding welfare say this
is a big one I'm not going to some of
this I'm going to leave until next time
as I blend some features of it into a
large development larger interpretation
there's a lot of good scholarship here I
mean the transnational context is that
the American welfare state is relatively
late it's been relatively small and it's
been relatively private side is writing
about this here by excellent writing the
fighter of grading by Jacob hacker on
these subjects it put put the
institutions together the presidents
have been have been it seems to be
interested particularly in Big Bang Big
Bang welfare state enterprises as social
security in 1936 that was Roosevelt's
baby the Medicare 1965 that was at least
Lyndon Johnson's baby or the Affordable
Care Act in 2009-2010 that was Obama
shared with Capitol Hill boat Obama was
it's a very big deal for for Obama but
Congress has heard basic also to the
building of the American welfare say
there's a stream of smaller or
incremental measures of mental gauge
mothers measures that have come out of
Capitol Hill a long period of time in
children's benefits in 1912 signed by
President Taft maternal benefits in 1921
signed by President Harding a public
housing in 1937 which Wagner talked FDR
into disability benefits the 1956 signed
by Eisenhower Supplemental Security
income in 1972 signed by Nixon the
Earned Income Tax Credit 1975 signed by
Ford the GI bills after world war two
and since then have basic had basically
had congressional provenance provenance
that is Henry Waxman the Congress from
California is said to have generated 24
distinctive expansions of Medicaid in
the 1980s and that's documented this is
a full book talking about that says
you're really quite extraordinary all of
it adds up the other is a some recent
path dependent scholarship that is to
say American political development folks
they like to talk about path dependence
the big thing that is to say what
happened a long time ago effects deeply
what's happened since then that's path
dependence it says some path dependence
interpretations it's good by the way it
makes a lot of sense to say that into a
right scholarship that says it the keys
on Congress or three arguments that have
come down and one of them the first
thing I'm going to leave developing or
boring into the next time one is this is
that around nineteen hundred or so that
decorates decades around 1900 Congress
was by the way it operated discouraged
the country from building big efficient
national federal bureaucracies the way
that Swedes the French and the Germans
have got bid have dealt and maintained
big efficient public bureaucracies I was
just leaving it up in the air that
argument they are made by skowronek and
by city of scotch ball which is very
good when I think and not a part of this
picture is that building early on
an expensive and big and need to be
administered in the fashion when people
who aren't sterling money stealing money
are frittering it away and in a Swedish
or German fashion was not easy to do in
the USA as of 1900 it was just part of
the picture that's one argument a second
path dependence argument is this one
that the progressive taxation which the
US during the era I've talked about here
got the u.s. into it a big distinctive
way the progressive lactation is the
basic resource for the Treasury for the
federal government was very good it
plays a lot of people and you know it
struck two for the progressive cause but
in the long run it's not an effective
generator of a lot of revenue and as
ample revenue doesn't easily come in
from it it doesn't work as well as I say
a value-added tax which is regressive
and mina value-added tax is invisible
where is your income tax is quite
visible and therefore vulnerable and
also it's a subject to fiddling who
threw a tax breaks of the soil Apollo
Bauer was talking about last time in
history the taxation code the tax code
is among other things in history of tax
breaks and fiddling and that part of
that attaches after all to the income
tax itself finally the final argument
here is that despite Jacob hacker
recently that the some of the important
moves by Congress by Congress that have
affected the way they private the
welfare state operates have come in old
revenue bills that we haven't heard much
about in 1942 in 1954 that had the
effect of shunting supportive welfare
provision over into private companies as
1953 1954 Jacobson a very good job with
that one I got three more items to do
here and it's just about going to be
right I think and then there where we
are yep I'm on schedule and maybe
baffling you that I might excuse me
again what did I do I see don't want to
do that ok now we're gone past World War
two and and the the last three of these
are our impulses from the late late 40s
and 50s and 60s and I guess they extend
into the yeah into the 70s and it
actually into the 80s there but not
recently
the two items are going to talk about
next time a more recent are still
ongoing but these are these these are
out there in the decades after World
would do one of them is this and I think
this merits inclusion unless they've
written in peace on this a chapter about
it suitable looked into it at one point
I found it fascinating is that after
World War Two one of the big things
going on in the Western world in Japan
was just shut this never again we're
never going to have a rotten economy the
way that we did in the nineteen thirty
we just can't have that anymore we need
prosperity with not only that much of
the world is wrecked afternoon after
nineteen Germany and Japan a particular
this mess out there this prosperity
economic growth have needed all over the
place so let's forget everything else
for a while and try to do that also the
the Cold War which came into effect
pretty quickly in 1946-47 supply to the
initial reason for the American
government to try to juice up its own in
the European a Japanese economy so they
can keep up with or ahead of the
Russians that was it all that was there
so we have these impulses its
ideological as well as foreign policy
inspiration at that time so a lot of
energy went into thinking into at the
cost of other things as juicing up the
economy is making him run well and in
fact for the quarter of a century after
1945 through 1973 is so the economies of
the Western world and Japan are very
successful off the growth of the growth
rate and a lot of people would give
right arm on the left on right now for
their growth rate these countries so
exhibited during those decades split it
between Congress and the executive the
generally speaking on on the executive
side what we did come have coming ashore
come that came assured in after all
after the war during and after the wall
was the location of on the Keynesian
macroeconomic coordination in the
executive branch to the council of
economic advisers and the presidents and
a president's took on the responsibility
to coordinate this is what put forth by
the this seems to have emanated from the
experience of World War two and juggling
the economies in Britain us during that
time as well as in the u.s. particularly
the Employment Act of nineteen forty six
which gave the executive branch the
mandate after all to keep twirling
denials to deal with inflation and with
growth and with
on particularly unemployment there was
at so that's an executive saying beyond
that in these decades on the presidents
are not unimportant the president's i
found i read brian burton a surprise me
I read Eisenhower's of memoirs and such
Eisenhower was a big booster you know a
big promoter of highways and dams and
canals was eisenhower but I he's a
booster as well as a boaster you read as
a as memoir is a quote fries now as
memoirs this is about the highway system
that was put on the books in 1956 the
internet I way system which we all drive
on today the biggest peacetime
construction project of any description
ever undertaken by the United States or
any other country that's eyes now we're
talking that's the way he talks about is
baby doing that's quite interesting
quite interesting yes so and and I think
in the case of Kennedy we weren't i'm
talking about it extends through the
Kennedy presidency in 1963 Kennedy was
Kennedy's made if you look at what
Kennedy was really interested in it
seems like and the presidency during his
brief you as as president it was a
couple of things it was is trade that
this trade bill is trade expansion bill
of 1962 which he went to the wall for it
was chief project during second year in
office and then his tax cut and night
which came into effect finding in 1964
after he died in November of 1963 but
the tax code was a big thing for him and
it was at the end of the day the way
they were justifying it was it was it
was a long-term economic growth kind of
move apparently the way to the writers
talk about it that is it brought the one
thing at bronte I said this last time
the top bracket tax down from 71 pics on
what ninety-one percent which is a
wartime level two fifty percent and I
made a permanent that is it wasn't to be
just a jolt to the economy right now to
help with during the next year or two it
was a long term long term settlement of
American the taxation history and it's
one of those is one of those path
dependence thinks as taxes haven't gone
higher than that sense since Kennedy's
move all right is that but then Congress
and the executive I I was struck by this
that i found that looking at it in one
the era of the late 40s 49 plus 1950s
and through Kennedy in 1963 stands out
as an era of surprising surprising and
surprisingly consequential legislative
activity it's not leastly looked on that
way and we looked at enough a lot of
conflict that but it was yeah not an
awful lot of complex a lot of cross
party legislating is sometimes one party
government and one of the other party
didn't like it but still generally
speaking a lot of cross party
legislating and I coated this I thought
about this that is economics as the the
animation that what they're aiming for
was it's all economic productivity some
combination of productivity efficiency
development and growth these are near
sentence when no to the tool they were
probably exactly Synod synonymous with
any other that meant some among it an
awful lot of infrastructure development
so a big binge of infrastructure
development and of course we look back
at that we say we don't like this stuff
they don't like the highways they don't
like the shopping malls we don't like
the bad fish coming into the Great Lakes
because they built the canal up there
and so on there's a lot of stuff we
don't like I mean it's not correct to
look back at the young these days at
what they do but things he'd be
consequential without being admirable
and we have to think about that it's a
lot of consequence reality back there
this is my slide 18 I made a list of
laws or parts of laws that came through
through legislating generally
cooperative legislative between the
Congress and the presidency but notice
they did this by legislating not by
somebody's executive order was actually
putting things on to the books through
legislating they the creation of the
peer review system and through the NSF
which were many of us are familiar with
they brought that in the majority
registration really didn't like that
they wanted more top-down bureaucrats
having more of an and deciding we should
get the money an authorization by law
offshore oil drilling came about 53
developed they bought the seat when
Saint Lawrence Seaway through
authorization 54 they authorized and
brought into existence by law a private
atomic energy in 1954 they brought in
flexible prices in agriculture the
warehouses are filling up with crops
that because the parity prices that the
government guaranteed
so I the growth friendly revenue mashup
measures under eyes now and also some
kind of the Kennedy in 1964
liberalisation of international trade
particularly under Eisenhower in 55
cooperating with the Democrats on
Capitol Hill and Kennedy in 1962 the
upper Colorado River storage project
that's a mouthful but what that means is
big dams like Lake Powell and well
substantially anyway Arizona that is
putting the dams in effects of supply
water downstream from the Colorado River
up in the high Rockies this was probably
the last very big big big dam enterprise
by the USA the and then I way program in
1956 that is this is the this is the big
item in at all the whatever else I got
here the National the space program in
1958 got to keep up with the Russians 84
science education in 1958 area
redevelopment by the Democrats in 61
communication satellite and putting
together a public-private cooperation to
do put a satellite up in there in 1962
it's really quite an interesting
interesting i think sequence of stuff i
got this i stuck at the bottom of the
previous previous slide here this quote
i copped out of the newspaper from
Schiller recently he over and the
economics department shoulder what does
he say it's worth noting if the u.s.
achieved its fastest he commits growth
since nineteen twenty nine in the 50s
and 60s the time of my government
expenditure on the Internet highway
system which was launched in 1956 there
at all okay post-world war two
prosperity no next to last for today is
the civil rights revolution Civil Rights
revolution our resolution and I want to
put this into a transnational setting
which isn't isn't always done and in the
American case the world war two is a key
to this world war two I think anyway
right reading the history as of 1939
before the war came on for the US the
the southern racial caste system was
pretty solidly in place you know what it
wasn't getting upset was down there not
much was going on
but the war shook things up in a big way
in this country and other places the war
began a lot of reasons the war became
partly a campaign against racism at
least on the European front by the
Allies at least partly that's an African
Americans got entailed into the army
into the workforce in an important way I
think the country seemed to look around
and say what I've been doing all these
decades it was so nasty the whites
saying that looks like that anyway so
what happened was that when war ended
and the civil rights civil rights the
public opinion polls took off they
started surging toward the more
favorable attitude civil rights among
whites you see that starting in the mid
1940s and I just zooming up to the mid
1960s when the civil rights revolution
in the US through legislative action did
occur after all in the mid-1960s 1964 in
1965 and some well now the important the
interesting thing is that there was a
similar post-world war two policy surge
across the the other ex British settlers
state says USA Australia New Zealand
Canada is a quotation from michael lind
michael lind the other english-speaking
democracies Britain Canada Australia New
Zealand not just the settler state but
Britain itself all abolished their white
supremacist civil rights laws and whites
only immigration policies at the same
time that the United States did it's
basically the 1970s says centering in
the 1960s what we're seeing is a similar
comparable are the same impulse that's
extending across these these countries
and it's it's a familiar pack of
countries the you know the xtube if
you're looking for comparisons and
similarities and analogy so there it is
and now they're meant for the Americans
after all that meant a large
african-american population that wasn't
the case in these other colonies except
for South Africa which in some respects
fits into this generalization also in
the other countries that means some
Asian peoples of possible Asian
immigrants it means indigenous peoples
in Australia New Zealand and in Canada
and what happened in the mid sixties
mean the general pattern is of an
extension of universal citizenship
rights including bonuses voting rights
across the race these various countries
and every one of these countries made a
move
that made moves in that direction around
in the 1960s there's also a D
racialization so to speak of immigration
in these various countries I mean the
effect of the immigration act in 1965
and the USA was to open the USA to
immigration from from Asia for example
it had been quite closed until nineteen
sixty-five and all these that the other
countries also put laws on the books d
racial izing their immigration policy
Canada did it for example in 1962 it's
really quite interesting and the the I
would like somebody should make a good
study make a study comparative study of
the evolution of policy positioning by
the American democratic party on the one
hand and the Australian Labor Party on
the other hand these are very comparable
parties in some ways I mean they were a
century ago they were both stirring
stirring the guardians of white
supremacy in the USA and an Australian
in Australia was chiefly to guard
against immigration from Asia and the
u.s. it was that on the west coast as
well as attitude to the merit the
african-american population but it was
those parties Australian Labor on
American Democrats who had that
particular very strong policy position
but after the war both of them
apparently about the same time surged
into being leave the spear carriers for
civil rights in Australia and in the USA
it looks like on a common schedule it's
very interesting now the the presidency
in the Congress the president took the
lead the courts did in the USA in the
1950s and 60s we know that we know that
they started with Truman Truman went out
front publicly with a pro civil rights
position in 1946 more than any president
had done that in the 20th century
previous president and then the courts
got into it we know that too but
Congress was laggard I'm not going to
take this up today this is something
that's going to fold into my discussion
on Tuesday Congress is very laggard on
civil rights we know that too is we all
learned
in elementary school that's there but
I'll take it out next time the last two
were getting fairly close but we're not
violating too much the rules of this
game the next one I'm calling sleek
inning the economy by which I mean the
onset of the the in search of
neoliberalism and to the economies and
they political thinking in the political
action of the world in the 1970s and in
the 1980s the transnational setting was
that economic formulas that had worked
before it didn't seem to be working
anymore what would the coming of
stagflation and the rest is a lot of
despair and a lot of twirling on
something like what Hoover was doing in
1931 people didn't know what to do in
prescribing policy formulas so well so
one result of that apparently was that
neoliberalism I came in and and and and
and had just made a very big impression
across the much of the world and again
especially a commonality it appears
again it's the same pack of countries
across the u.s. and the other British
British countries as US the UK Australia
New Zealand Canada all took very very
heavily to do liberalism in the 1970s
particularly in the 1980s what that
meant was moves into privatization into
a deregulation into tax cuts and to
weakening of the unions and back a back
away from Keynesian formulas for
managing the economy all those things
are going on in all these countries and
various measures it's interesting that
in New Zealand's a very stirring the old
liberal program was carried I was
undertaken and carried by a Labour Party
government not by a Conservative Party
government down now it's quite
interesting now presidency in Congress
there are there there are differences
there and their differences between the
parties are clear enough very clear
differences between the parties and the
US and the UK an odd one in New Zealand
but the US in the UK I mean Reagan and
Thatcher or one thing and the Democrats
and the
a labor rights over there or another
thing at wayward Reagan being
particularly tough on unions and on on
taxes Thatcher put the CLE tough on
unions and privatization all this is a
well known but generally speaking
generally speaking that aside mean there
are these partisan difference but
generally thinking beyond that the what
I'm calling the neoliberal impulse of
invested both branches of the American
government and both parties in the days
of Ford and Carter and Reagan it's kind
of the comprehensive invasion sort of
with partisan differential they're not
much differential different thing
between Congress and the presidency
generally speaking they cooperated some
taking the lead on something some on
others but it's something and it's a lot
of this is the Democrats for example and
it was under under Carter and Ford
before him and with a Democratic
Congress in the 70s that we got
deregulation of trucking deregulation of
the airlines the regulation of railroads
the regulation of oil and gas prices the
first in regulation of the Savings and
Loan Banks came in nineteen eighty this
is all under the Democrats this is all
before reagan reached the white house
and went into his own deregulatory moves
and it's a tax cutting in 1981 the
revenue Act of 1978 were done by the
democrats was a slash of capital gains
taxes that was brought about by Carter
in a Democratic Congress that's also
under the Democrats there was a lot in
short there's a lot of cross partisan
lawmaking at that time I'd seen and it
tends to get overlooked for that reason
that's people look back look back in
there say they want to see one party
battering the other party if one party
isn't battering the other party it must
be that nothing is going on which is not
a good luck way of looking at the world
I think that the the neoliberal is that
the end of my list yes that's it their
liberal impulse it's a it's a surprising
and powerful thing that came came along
and they very surprising surprising and
powerful intellectually powerful and
politically politically impactful
and the impact goes on it's but I do
think that it did its work so to speak
as an impulse so a while ago it's not
right now there's not i don't see
innovation out there now somebody
brought up brought this up last time I
think the that yo liberalism as an
innovative bringing about different
kinds of deregulation and tax cuttings
and so forth it's pretty much petered
out and being innovative maybe 10 to 15
years ago something like that now I'm
I'm going to stop here are going to
leave the last two items number 12 and
number 13 which are what is a climate
change i'm going to deal with and the
problem of dealing with debts and
deficits I'll take those up next time
they're both on the table right now
there's still on the table plus such
take me about 10 minutes next time in
the rest of it will be an interpretive
discussion picking up a couple of themes
and I want to dwell on one is the they
would I began at the beginning the place
of Congress in the in the legitimizing
of the system that is the relation to be
Congress on the one hand legitimacy and
stability of the system on the other I
want to take that up and then I want to
take up as a separate matter and this
picks up some of the instances some of
the 13 also the messiness of
congressional law making a messiness
mean inconstancy incoherence particular
ISM and how that comes down what it
amounts soon the some respects a bright
side to in some respects not a bright
side and some respects aside which isn't
clear whether it's right or not that's
it
so we we have time for a couple of
questions before calling it a day no we
got no I got what I see I see I see I'm
wrong I thought what do we haven't told
how long we got any way they take too
long did I take too long no okay go
ahead sure no questions that's all right
okay I solid everything I I had a
question about the sort of empire
building I can't quite hear you keep
going I've a question about the colonial
cashew you raised and he said well that
the u.s. didn't have colonies because of
congressional opposition yeah and so um
not just let me think of some of the
European cases where you had strong
parliamentary or congressional
opposition to colonies and yet you had a
bunch of colonies so in France and
Britain at various times you have
parliamentary strong opposition to
adding more colonists to the Empire and
yet a combination of factors they're
like let's see so competition with
immediately adjacent powers in Europe
action by individual military leaders on
the spot very clever royal or executive
action led to you basic developing
colonies in those situation even though
Parliament originally was dead set
against these colonies so I I just
encourage use you right up I suppose to
add in some consideration of these other
factors as well as congressional
opposition that might have been
responsible for the u.s. guessing
colonies or not get some time okay well
taken that's I well said well said I
don't know what to say in response it
just seems to make good sense I do see
the the instances are they there
instances for several decades President
Grant really wanted the seed Santo
Domingo which meant the Dominican
Republic and they were stopped them they
just stopped them and the president's in
the 20s or Teddy Roosevelt and they're
mucking about in the Caribbean
you couldn't keep their fingers kept
reaching for Haiti and Nicaragua and the
Dominican Republic again and there was a
steering opposition of that on Capitol
Hill and that which is interesting and
it is true after all that the Congress
has an awful lot of power basically the
presidency we should not mean a case
with so much anyway with Rob groups in
the British Parliament then maybe they
can be overridden in the British
Parliament the French is another case
the committee's are pretty strong there
too i don't how to think about that one
during these decades yeah but I hear you
him you haven't mentioned Germany and
France much in your nose I wonder what's
the implication of that because I think
of there being two of the six major
powers yes in the world I think what's a
good question let me see now i think
that one answer to that is that the for
some purposes when i'm looking for peer
countries out there to make comparisons
with the British setlist States and
Britain itself make for the best
territory I mean I mean for example the
neoliberalism there's a style of
neoliberalism that sets in to the all
these British countries have very
similarly where he got in the continent
and you run into economies that are
corporate and style and they didn't
react in the same way so far as I know
about it to the stagnation problem run
in the 1970s then also the the colonies
the well actually the Germans I mean the
Germans did have colonies in Africa but
they lost them and they lost them in the
will well one they just went away so
there isn't any comparison there that's
possible and as we get it past World War
two so we can't do that one for some
purposes in a German so I mean I was
talking about gray powell rivalry or
with building an industrial economy in
the late 19th century meaning the
Germans are they out there right on the
list there right on the list or after
World War Two I didn't mention the
Germans but the
the after all the animation toid the
economic growth that will be there in
Germany and Japan as well as in the
other country they just didn't specify
the country's a specification would
bring them up in an artery the place of
wrecked after all and is a and is a very
strong exhibit for economic growth in
the starting in the late nineteen
forties no question about that Germany
yeah better than England better than
England their respect is an instance you
know that's the best I can do thank you
waiting excuse my just one question do
the namely when you can to think where
it's leaking of the economy what Kendra
I can't might hear it putting subliminal
word in your impulses slinking what ok
it's like an i go yeah I made that up
term I know you did and it suggests
however a positive judgment that is to
say making something sleek implies you
approve of what's happened whereas it
would seem to me that some of what you
list indeed that happened with the sleek
name of young economy would be judged by
at least a portion of the United States
has in negative terms well I'm here to
be descriptive I see your problem i see
that but I do manage to be descriptive I
think it's a plot was looking for
descriptive terminus this season mean
eyes I couldn't find a good one
otherwise I didn't particularly wanted
to say dbo level you know liberalism is
too clumsy so I mean it as descriptive I
don't mean it as a normative and maybe
it comes across and fashion they didn't
quite intend you know
fitting into that category and finally
left and relaxed quite a close i'm
having a little trouble again there's a
muffle today on the mic i don't know I
New Zealand fits into the category that
you're you're you're discussing but the
way works out or we were museum a couple
of years after the reforms were
instituted by the labour government and
there is a wayward separate worked out
in new zealand vs the united states is
very different in new zealand the people
in implemented reforms were in the
ministries whereas why it was not
academic in united states were a lot of
academics you at the alcohol the school
yeah you had in the University of it
robert eric writing about antitrust app
in new zealand it was all in the
ministry's had nothing to do with that
you know it was all it kind of becomes
so the weight worked the mechanics have
worked out in New Zealand I don't know
about the other country where do they
get their ideas us pardon it was all
mine what the ideas were from the US yes
that's enough was enough but they it was
not transmitted to the to the lawyers I
mean it's like the Chicago folks going
to Chile I mean it doesn't know this I
ideas good night I doc I don't care
whether it went through people who were
it doesn't make a difference to me that
I mean are they impacting us it worked
out it was much broader and deeper
because you you had the in economics in
non economics you actually had a
volatile
involve lawyers in New Zealand those
nada zero not about none of one those
there was no one in onyx move oh I see
the point why do they need it if they're
just borrowing ideas from the US I mean
it's too small to have a law in
economics movement where do they need it
that's just it son but they got the
ideas I probably know I think it's just
that the doget movement was in some ways
a narrower responding to it yet no
accessories at the time that were nearly
bankrupt and that there was no broader
political support was it when it was
much much more narrowly focus well
that's not an awful lot of broad
political support in the USA either I
mean deregulation did not have bronze
political support it comes out of it
scoops out of the Academy's into the
minds of people in the government it's
not out and none of the pressure groups
out they wanted the deregulation just
not true one more question we have time
for it if there is one yes oh I'm just
trying to fill sounds hot I haven't
noticed any where in your discussion an
evaluation of the character the strength
or weakness of character of congressmen
senators or representatives and I think
a lot of them would make good neighbors
and good cousins but I think and I'd
like you to comment on my feeling that
they all act like irresponsible children
and they hope the money will keep coming
in because they know how to spend it
well there's a lot of that I mean in the
I yeah I mean they are they are they're
not better than we are they may be worse
in some respects in the way they operate
their lives and their careers after all
what would you expect i mean that's so I
mean they I mean the Congress doesn't
have a good press when people have
looked at the people i mean Tocqueville
writing about the house this is not an
animal bunch of people they come in they
fight on the floor they spent too much
it's just it's not a good group it's not
and and and and responding to two
animations from interest groups are from
people who give money or for
constituents what would you expect
that's what you're going to get in a
legislature where you got individual
members because well because it goes it
goes way back there it is there it is so
it's a just have to figure that in into
it all and if you can invent a
counterfactual world where they're going
to be better people that would be
something but it's tough it's tough to
they have to get elected after all and I
and what do they like I remember I was
watching some time ago was some
television program where somebody who's
interviewing house pages that's back
when they had them you know pages you
know these kids who are pages on the
House floor I get this wide-eyed kid who
comes in and he says you know I really
like it in the house it's just like high
school you said this was like I was cool
that's what they like and it is what I
made there it is it's um so of course
all those things are going to be true so
she's excuse me oh geez yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so on that note we will
adjourn and take things up again on
Tuesday what's that again I'm a little
adjourn until next I get up again next
Susie will do that sure yep well they
did
you